you use the stones again we'd be going  in short-handed you know look he's still  got the stones so so let's gonna use  them to bring everyone back just like  that yeah just like that even if there's  a small chance that we can undo this I  mean we owe it to everyone who's not in  this room to try if we do this how do we  know it's gonna end any differently than  it did before because before you didn't  have me hey new girl everybody in this  room is about that superhero life and if  you don't mind my asking where the hell  have you been all this time  there are a lot of other planets in the  universe and unfortunately they didn't  have you guys  [Music]  I like this one  [Music]  let's go get this son  [Music]